Labour peer Lord Adonis has apologised
for sharing a cartoon mocking sergeant
Jeffords background it showed the new
Home Secretary with the caption I just
want to settle in get organized then
deport my parents sergeants father has
passed away by his own rhetoric Lord
Adonis is a privileged white peer to
racially humiliate the son of a Muslim
immigrant merely for choosing a
different political party is racism
nobody's left-wing status immunizes them
from racism and this is an own the only
example of racism directed at Javed from
the left he's been called an Uncle Tom
and a coconut insults designed to
racially shamed minorities who think
outside the left-wing box such abuse
encourages political apartheid if you
call for integration social mobility and
diversity you can't also object along
racial lines to political diversity now
I've never voted conservative in my life
but the left don't own minorities so
ditch the colonialism Thanks
we can think for ourselves Majid I
completely agree with you I think that
racism wherever it occurs is despicable
and let's just hear from Android onus
who did comment on that tweet and this
is what he said on reflection
Sajid I think the cartoon is too
personal and in poor taste I have
deleted it
I am sorry Andrew and I also was on
Twitter that day calling out the racism
that Sajid Javid was experiencing with
people using those racial terms of
racial abuse and I am someone who gets
trolled by racist every single day they
come from both sides usually in my case
from the far-right but I do get trolled
by the left sometimes as well and it's
there is no place in public or any other
discourse for racism it has to be called
out regardless of where it is on the
political spectrum it is not a political
issue it is an issue of racism and it is
completely wrong in terms of the bigger
issue you raised about this idea that
the left have them and not Leone the
black vote I agree with you I think
there is an imperialist attitude in some
parts of the left but historically the
left have enjoyed the vote majority of
black and minority ethnic people and
it's quite an interesting phenomenon
because if you think about it so many
ethnic minority communities in this
country do have values that emphasize
enterprise faith strong families social
mobility you know they are
they are in some ways traditional
traditional conservative values and the
question is not why aren't there black
conservatives but why aren't there more
and that is because the Conservative
Party have failed to have policies and
rhetoric that appeal to people from
minority backgrounds even when they are
natural conservative and this Windrush
scandal is the latest example of
something that makes many minority
people feel alienated from the
conservative so I think that is a
problem for the Conservatives and I
absolutely agree we should not look at
Nick minority people with this single
narrative idea they're all some lump who
are left-wing that's absolutely what is
what is actually highlighted all this is
you've got sergeant Javed who is the son
of an immigrant a bus drivers son who
has done incredibly well he's got a
successful business record comes into
Parliament has been a cabinet minister
held different positions done well in
all of them and is now the first ethnic
minority individual to hold one of the
great offices of state Home Secretary
and it is terrific I think it's
something this country should celebrate
here and I think he's going to do a
great job because he started off
straightaway by saying we've had a
hostile and attitude to immigration I'm
gonna change that to compliant kind of
trade aggression here's the other point
look how far we've come in the 80s we
had only four ethnic minority MPs and
one in the house Lords today they're
almost a hundred between the two houses
and a cabinet minister and soon we'll
have an ethnic minority prime minister
in the sky and one of those first floor
was Diane Abbott who was one of the
first four black and peaceful actors who
stood up and in parliament at the
despatch-box
also condemned as a racist abuse it's
against hosts it's against illegal
immigration there is a degree of
hostility but let's move away from the
political side for a moment and just
more on the sort of freedom of speech
because I remember a few weeks ago you
and I debated a so-called Scottish
comedian and he did a video I think of a
his girlfriend's dog doing Heil Hitler
salutes and saying to CK yes yes
absolutely and and you then as I recall
you seem to be in support of him doing a
jokey video but you appear to be against
a jokey cartoon now I might have got
this wrong so let me let me clarify that
I think that the distinction in that
debate if you will recall wasn't and he
this young lad was criminalized for a
terrible joke
made it very clear in that debate that I
was I found the joke offensive because
it involved shouting she kale at this
dog and making it before Marcy salutes I
didn't think it was funny but my point
was nobody should be criminalized for a
bad joke it would be the equivalent of
Lord Adonis being criminalized for this
tweet and so I think that's slightly
different what I'm talking about here is
I was offended at that's another point
for me as is is the cartoon racist or is
it sentiments racist in your is the idea
that it's the idea that one skin color
defines what one should think
politically and then the notion the
tendency among some on the left that
they own or they monopolize the ethnic
minority vote and let me show you jeremy
corbyn's tweet ok demonstrational so
because i find this incredibly racially
patronizing this Tweety's he said that
some only labor can be trusted to unlock
the talent of black asian and minority
ethnic people and it's that kind of you
know there's a bigotry of low
expectations is so wrong yes so sad yes
because you know we are 19 uncommon
independent so sad the early 1960s we
talked about over fifty years ago then
Martin Luther King says judge me not by
the color of my skin but the content of
my character and here we have today
comments like Uncle Tom and coconut I
think it's so sad that today we should
not be an issue at all we've come a long
way anyone can get it we regardless of
race regardless of religion escape
regardless of background this is an
aspirational country with opportunity
for all yep Carol takes I find it
incredible have lauded honest apology as
if the cartoon we put out there as if
it's okay no because he said sorry it's
really not okay and let's just look at
some of the other vile examples of stuff
that was put out on Twitter this was by
named labor campaigners auntie amber
replaced by Uncle Tom the most
overcooked coconut in the history of
coconut ism has become Home Secretary
Tory scum hiding behind a brown coconut
in the in the new Home Secretary you
know just to say we don't know they're
like they purport to be we can't say
these particulars but lots of them were
name is a very prominent labor
campaigners said vile stuff on Twitter
and you know you've shown that tweet
from Corbin there Corbin's job in all of
this
should have been to come out and condemn
absolutely the racist abuse of Sajid
Javid but he didn't do that sachet
himself who was in the House of Commons
actually invited him to the despatch-box
to do exactly that and he didn't come
and this has been the problem with
anti-semitism he didn't stamp on it
early enough he should have stamped on
that two years ago three years that boy
should I am labor right to reply and
this is the Shadow Chancellor John
McDonnell addressing this very points
this issue of racism anti-semitism
racism has affected our community we
cannot tolerate it and we can't tolerate
racism in any party across parties we've
got to campaign against an overall you
know I think anybody who's genuinely
committed to the struggle against racism
needs to call out wherever it happens I
am somebody who was never voted
conservative but I'm happy to say that I
stand beside sided Javid when he is
defending himself against racist abuse I
also want us to look at the Conservative
Party where there is also racism this
isn't just an issue for the left we had
a counselor who shared a horrific racist
joke being reinstated to win the council
and then congratulated by the chair of
the party so this is a problem in
society and you know just listening to
you Karen I I hear you but in the way I
feel like you're this is a we live in a
country where racism is pervasive this
is not the only place that manifests it
is a huge place for racism but I also if
you flip this the other way look at the
celebration of what migration and what
ethnic minorities have brought to this
country it's less than 15 percent of the
population of this country and look at
what they've contributed over the
decades we wouldn't be one of the top
ten economies in the world
entrepreneurs without without right the
contribution of the immigrants saying we
will not tolerate in politics like they
have tolerated it they've it's not
Corbin's fault that he has members of
his party that the tweet this vile stuff
however it is his responsibility to talk
about it and to stamp it out by by
sacking members from the party who do
this you are to to my earlier point I
think the key here for me is to assume
the way somebody will vote based on
their skin color and
to consider them somehow treacherous to
their ethnicity or identity if they
don't tow that line is the issue but
those are patterns are a lot more
complex than reducing them down to one
single issue so for example Sajid Javid
and and actually generally minority
voters who vote conservative may have
overlooked some other historic racism
they believe or allege could have
existed in the conservative party
because they may have been more
disgusted for example by the
anti-semitism in the Labor Party but
people make multiple calculations when
they're voting and it isn't only down to
one issue and I think that's the nub of
it for me to reduce somebody down to you
know their ethnicity and then define
their political allegiance based on that
for these races